i have a matrix a
it is an n by n matrix and let me just
write its rows like this let me just
write it as
r1 we could call them row vectors maybe
r2 i'm not doing it too formally this is
just really the save on writing and then
it has an i throw
r i
and then you keep going it has some
that's an i right there then it has a j
th row r j and you keep going you get to
the nth row it has n rows and n columns
so you get to r n just like that that is
my matrix where just to be just to make
sure you get what i'm saying
r
so if i have a let's say the kth
r sub k is equal to
a k 1
a k maybe i'll write it as a vector a k
all the way to a k
n so this is just your standard
representation i wrote it this way
because we're just going to be dealing
with rows in this video and it makes our
notation a little bit easier
now let me let's just focus on these two
rows right here
and let me define another matrix b
another matrix b
that is also an n by n matrix
and it's identical to matrix a
except for one row
so it's identical to matrix a except for
one row you have r one just like that
it's the same as that one there
r2 keep going go down to ri even that
one's identical but rj
rj i've now replaced i'm replacing rj
with
r
j
minus a scalar multiple of ri minus c
times
r i
so minus a scalar multiple of that i've
replaced r j with that so this is
equivalent to
the row operations we do when we did our
gaussian elimination or when we put
things in reduced row echelon form and
everything else in this matrix is the
same as a
it's all the way down
to rn
all the way down to rn
let me write this is our matrix b so
let's think about what the determinant
of b is going to be equal to
let me do it in blue
the determinant
the determinant of b
well you can immediately say say you
could say that b is equivalent to
well you can imagine two vectors
let me
let me you could imagine two matrices
one matrix that looked like this
one matrix that looked like r1
r2
all the way down
ri
all the way down to rj
and then you keep going down to rn
that's one matrix which you may have
already noticed is identical to a that's
one matrix and then you could have
another matrix here
and then you could all you could have
another matrix here that looks like this
that looks like this it's identical
everywhere
r 1
r 2
r i some dots there just to show you i'm
going to skip some rows skip some more
rows r and then you have c times r 1
c times
r
sorry c times r i
c times ri let me do that in a different
color this is
ri right here so r
i
and then you just keep going down you
just keep going down to r
n
now the determinant of b you could view
as the determinant of this guy let me
write this here the determinant
of b
is equal to the determinant of this guy
plus the determinant of this guy
hopefully you remember a couple of
videos ago that if one matrix let's say
i have two matrices that are identical
in every way except for
except for one row so these two matrices
are completely identical except for
what's going on on the jth row here you
have a r sub j here you have a c times r
sub i so it's a scalar multiple of a row
that you had up here this guy so this is
ri this is the i throw
here it's an ri here you have an ri but
here you have another version of our
scalar multiple of ri while here you
have an rj
now if you have another matrix that is
essentially identical to these two
matrix matrices except for this one row
and in that one row it looks like the
addition of these two matrices and let
me put a negative here
let me put a negative here so if you
kept
this matrix completely identical but if
you were to take if you replace it with
the sum of these two rows so r j minus c
times ri you'll get this matrix right
here you'll get matrix b and we learned
that the determinant of b is equal to
the determinant of this guy and that guy
remember b is not the sum of these two
matrices b is identical to these two
matrices except for that one row where
b's j throw is equivalent to the j throw
of this guy plus the j throw of that guy
and when i talk about adding rows you're
just adding their corresponding elements
so i could rewrite let me rewrite this
just to be so you know this row would
look like
let me make it it would be a
a the first term would be a
j
minus
c times
a i 1. that would be the first term in
that row the second term in that row
would be a j 2 minus c times a i
2 and it would go all the way to
a j n minus c
a
sub i
n the nth column so that's all it means
by that so the determinant of b is equal
to the determinant of this plus the
determinant of this the determinant of
this well this thing is right here this
is our matrix a so this is going to be
the determinant of a
so this is the determinant
of a and what's the determinant of this
well let's break this down a little bit
more the determinant of this
is equal to what this is this is
completely equivalent to a except one of
its rows oh sorry this is completely
equivalent to
this matrix not equivalent to a be very
careful don't listen to everything i say
it's not equivalent to a we have the
difference is is that a has an rj here
this guy has a minus c times ri
so this is equivalent to
this is a completely equivalent to this
matrix
it's completely equivalent to
this matrix right here let me do it like
this so you have an r1
r2
it has you keep going then you have an r
i then you have another ri let me clean
this up a little bit let me clear this
out
let me clear that out just so i have
some space to work with
there you go
you have an ri you have that ri there
and then you have another ri
you have another ri right there
you have another ri and then you keep so
the jth row this is the j throw has an
ri there and you keep going and then you
have an r sub n
these two guys are completely equivalent
except for this guy has a minus c times
your times the j
row right that's what this was right
here this is the j throw everything
we're doing is in the j throw this has a
minus c times the jth row so this is
going to be equivalent to
so the determinant of this guy right
here
let me just be clear that i'm only
taking the determinant of this guy right
here it's going to be equal to
minus c times the determinant
times the determinant of let me write it
this way i'll just write minus c times
the determinant of
r1
r2
you have your first ri
your first ri and then in the j throw
you have another version of the ri and
then you go down to r sub n
so times that determinant this is just
the determinant of this i instead of
brackets i have those straight lines and
we saw this couple of videos ago if you
have a matrix you have a matrix and you
just multiply one of its rows by a
scalar in this case minus c it's
equivalent to minus c the determinant of
that new matrix is equal to minus c
times the determinant of your matrix so
that's all i'm saying right here but
what is the determinant of this matrix
you might have already noticed that it
has duplicate rows it has an ri and then
in the i throw
i throw
but then it has another ri in the jth
row
and the j throw remember we all got it
by we kind of decomposed this b matrix
right here it's the sum of or it's
determined it can be described as the
determinant of the sum of these two
things b isn't the sum of these two
things because b's every other element
is identical to every other element in
each of these guys but this guy right
here he has an he has duplicate rise and
what do we know about the determinant of
a matrix with duplicate entries the
determinant is zero so this entry right
here is zero minus c times zero zero so
the determinant of this whole thing is
zero
so the big takeaway right here is that
the determinant of b is equal to just
the determinant of this thing which was
the determinant of a
this is a very big takeaway it's going
to make our life very easy the
determinant of b
is equal to the determinant
of a
so if you start with some matrix and you
replace the j throw in this example but
any row if you replace any row
with that with that row minus some
scalar multiple of another row we picked
ri in this case that was the ri
you're going the determinant will not be
changed and you know yeah it's very you
have to be very particular about how you
say it because obviously if you just
multiplied something by a scalar you
were to change its determinant or if you
do other things but if you just take a
row
if you take the j throw and you replace
it
with the jth row minus c times the i
throw times uh some other
row which is equivalent to just a row
operation that we have been doing then
it will not change your determinant
which is a very big takeaway because now
we can carefully do some row operations
and know that the determinant will not
change